the twilight effect is the name of the
podcast it is
appropriate right i mean these movies
have quite an effect on people right
definitely
i'm sorry i didn't get a chance to
introduce myself last week um
i'm edward cullen
you're bella
come here yes
why was now the right time to do this
like re-watch podcast you know we saw
kind of this resurgence of twilight if
you will because we ended up being uh
released on netflix and then we were on
peacock and so it was kind of this
wonderful thing to see all of our
original fan base kind of get this fire
reignited and then but then see kind of
a whole new fan base join um and uh i
was kind of talking to one of my friends
about that one day and we were like
i could reminisce like this with my
co-stars and engage the fans and this
could probably be pretty fun um and so
that's kind of how the idea was born
that's amazing because i also feel like
the fans who grew up with
with twilight also grew up with you guys
and so it might be fun to kind of see
through their lens now too almost like
an adult lens oh yeah definitely yeah i
wanna like i'm interested to see how
their perspective has changed and like i
rewatched the films because i haven't
seen them for a very long time and did
your perspective change oh yeah they did
100 and you watched all five of them
right no i've only watched so we watched
them right before we discussed the film
so we're doing it kind of filmed by film
um so i rewatched the first one and was
just like oh there's so many things that
i didn't recognize or realize and also
being in it at the time like i think
it's hard to remove yourself absolutely
and so i actually got to watch it kind
of as a fan
i know what you are
say it
out loud
say it
vampire
obviously you and your cast members went
through a very unique experience and so
it's only fitting that you're bringing
them onto the podcast as some guests too
right you got to hear it from the
horse's mouth and had anyone never seen
the film since the premiere
um i'm sure i want to i don't know this
but i'm going to say billy burke is
going to be one that probably hasn't
seen it since the premiere um i think a
lot of us don't some people do they they
love kind of learning from their work
but like i don't love watching myself in
a film for me it's a negative because i
start going like oh i do that you know i
make that expression but now 10 years
later i'm like oh my god it's like baby
alice you know it's cool to see i'm
alice
hi
oh
you do smell good alice what are you
it's okay bella and i are gonna be great
friends
it's part of the journey yeah and the
evolution of ashley green right yeah um
so while making the movies i mean did
you guys realize how huge you would
become no i don't think anybody did
right like everyone was like what
happened and it's still kind of i think
you know there's certain elements to it
where you go oh these are why things
worked but
if if we knew the secret serum we would
replicate this all the time but yeah for
us we were i think the first premiere
it was insane it's the craziest red
carpet probably to date i've ever been
on and i was just like oh okay this is
something different oh my god yeah i
don't have to retake my job at the
belmont
i asked them whenever i went to film i
was like can i have my job back when we
get done and they were like i don't
think you'll need it obviously in this
podcast you're going to cover all things
twilight and your experiences from the
film i know that when in the trailer you
tease that you had a crush on someone on
set
do you want to spill now give us no
everything give us the watch the podcast
was that hard to revisit or a little
awkward or no like i think the biggest
takeaway for me i was like i don't think
i it was twilight was essentially my
first real job that i was on set
consecutively and uh and separating the
onset kind of chemistry that you have to
create with real life i don't think i
was quite i i was there wasn't skilled
in that yet i don't blame you with that
good looking cast
and you're with them all like it was the
first time i was experiencing that so of
course like i definitely developed a
crush well obviously you know you and
the cast you guys were mostly in your
20s when you're filming this i want to
know what was the vibe like shooting in
the pacific northwest like did you guys
get to like hang out and party together
yeah we well the first one we got we
went out
we terrorized the town a bit more yeah
yeah we were all in our 20s and like we
all went out and had a really great time
i think as the series progressed it got
a little more difficult sure um and so
it kind of forced us i think why we were
probably so close is that we had like
hotel hangs instead where like people
would play instruments and we would
drink you know what i want to know
though what was it like kind of living
in the insanity of kristen and rob's
relationship like was there any time
where you guys kind of feared for your
safety because it was i mean there was a
lot of attention around that i will
certainly say that like any time i
remember at one point i had to do a
press tour with rob and uh i'd never
done just solo he and i and i was like
oh this is a different experience like
we were in it and obviously we
experienced the fandom but you know rob
kristen taylor in particular like people
were you know people say it was like the
beatles and i was just like oh we're
breaking down barricades and we have to
be ushered out and this is nutty so yeah
you definitely kind of saw the
difference there and like we went out to
a bar at one point and you saw like a
head turn and then every single head
turn and we were like oh they knew you
guys were in there we got to go yeah
right right right because if people flog
people flock when they see you guys it's
just like everyone's excitement builds
on it and like everyone means well but
like it can get a little dangerous at
times well you know what's so cool you
know obviously kristen stewart is
nominated for an oscar this year robert
pattinson is batman i know is it kind of
amazing to see the cast thrive so many
years later it's yeah it's amazing i'm
so proud of them both and they 100
deserve it and i think you know twilight
was a wonderful thing for all of us but
i think there was like a certain amount
of work that everyone had to put in to
separate themselves from it and i feel
like they're finally people are seeing
both of them at their full potential so
that actually brings back to the podcast
though you know i feel like there might
be some people who have reservations
about kind of going back to uh a popular
franchise like this that they were part
of first you know but why was important
for you to be like why actually were you
like you know what i'm down to do this
because honestly like i so i've always
like i always say that our fans are like
the creme de la creme and they're
incredible and they're loyal and i have
a massive appreciation for that and was
kind of just like this was a big part of
our lives it was a big part of the fan's
life so why not be able we're so i think
we're so far removed at this point that
it becomes a lot more fun to talk about
there's the cast but also
the music the musicians the directors
the writers who adopted it you know from
melissa from the book to the screenplay
like i'm so interested to hear everyone
else's story because when we were in the
middle of it nobody asked each other
right i know what it was like for them
and i don't think we had the capacity to
kind of fully compute it at that point
it's more than anything a gift for the
fans now right and and for the new
generation that are kind of discovered
too now we recently spoke with taylor
for the past few years before that
happened it kind of it was just like the
twine moms stopping me in the street
because yeah it kind of just like
outgrew itself and it was in and i love
the twi moms um but only recently has it
like resurged and we have like these
like young teenagers you know starting
to to watch it and
it is it's crazy to see it come back
around have you noticed that shift yeah
definitely have you yeah
and it's that's what's what's cool about
i think like this resurgence is that you
see like our fans that were 13 years old
now kind of moms themselves perhaps um
but then seeing this like new kind of
youth come in also at the same time so
it's you know i feel like my mom was
like so twilight's like the gift that
keeps giving i'm like apparently like it
just it doesn't stop it is though
because there not only has been a huge
twilight you know resurgence because of
netflix but also tick tock i don't know
if you saw this have you seen olivia
rodrigo she's wearing like yeah very
very vintage twilight i better believe i
got calls about that did you everyone's
like do you know her and i was like no i
cannot get you tickets
it's sold out i was like do you have a
way in ash let us know they'll let you
know i'm a bit surprised that there
isn't like a twilight series or a
prequel um in development what do we
have to do to make that happen i'm so
surprised that that happened to be
honest because i think honestly there is
so much backstory with all these
characters too that you could 100 do a
series and not necessarily have to do a
remake yes but i think there's still so
much fascination behind it around these
characters do you think the colons could
have a spin-off maybe
probably would you want to be a part of
that i love being a vampire my only like
way that was like unfortunately i did
age so they were hardly no please
they'd have to put some money behind
just making us look young again 17 like
i appreciate you but 17 is a bit of a
stress that's true she's not we're not
in high school anymore folks okay last
question for you now that you've started
to re-watch the movies have your
thoughts change on the age-old question
team edward or team jacob or you're
always going to be loyal always going to
be loyal i'm like it's my brother that's
right yeah team edward allen thank you
so much for being here i'm so excited
for this it drops on march 15th you also
check out podcasts wherever you listen
to them awesome thank you so much for
being here